pour occuper les français dans cette
période du confinement chaque créateur
de contenus essaye de faire de son mieux
ainsi la société de production endemol
shine a décidé de mettre à disposition
des internautes l'intégralité de la
première édition de la star academy 1
prime en direct diffusée en 2001 qui
permet de découvrir aussi les premiers
pas de nico sur tf1 à l'époque tout
droit venu de france 2 où il était
chroniqueur pour christine bravo bonsoir
soyez le bienvenu en direct selon elle
voit quelques années de moins mais
toujours le même style inimitable
mais aujourd'hui c'est le grand soir
bienvenue soyez le bienvenu à star
académie
la star academy est le premier programme
de télé-réalité lancé par tf1 quelques
mois seulement après le lancement de
loft story sur m6 un programme qui aura
tenu huit saisons et dont la première
gagnante n'est autre que jennifer
[Applaudissements]
un programme qui aura révélé des stars
de la chanson comme nolwenn leroy elodie
frégé grégory lemarchal olivia ruiz ou
encore quentin mosimann une émission
culte dont on se souvient pour son
château ses professeurs d'expression
scénique comme armande altaï oscar sisto
mais aussi et surtout les fameux débrief
de rafina eu des couacs très bien on les
a tous entendu au sens vous faut alors
amis nostalgiques et rendez vous sur la
chaîne youtube officielle de la star ac
pour revivre les meilleurs moments de ce
programme culte alors c'est l'occasion
notamment de revoir le taux ni les
lancements de nikos aliagas qui nous dit
qu'ils étaient encore tout jeune
bon j'ai un truc à vous dire là dessus
après c'est vrai que les dirigeants de
tf1 avant sur la première de nikos se
disait ça ne va pas du tout le faire
c'est vrai je me rappelle et les douanes
sur très bon et dans le cas il ya eu des
événements non car alors il faut vous
avez bon j'aimerais rappeler dans le car
il est dans son monde
il est dans son lit dans son monde de
télévision si vous explique quand on
fait une émission garin car voilà ce qui
s'appelle un car régie dedans en fait il
ya tous la régie qui installé voilà le
lot il ya tout il ya les patrons de
chaînes gallais producteurs
il ya la sqri il ya le réalisateur et à
tout le monde qui dans ce cas pour
réaliser les missions donc caen basse
normandie dans le car il s'est passé des
choses ce n'est pas le cas je n'ai ni
compte bien entendu à la prensa le bac à
ma carte à lille et dans son monde haï
veut donner c'est le robin des bois 1 2
de mon cul cul mais il parle voilà il
est il est pas dans les rallyes mal
après le premier lancement de nikos fort
ce soir
soyez les bienvenus en direct sur tf1
nous sommes le samedi 20 octobre
il est exactement 20 ans 53 vous avez
entendu parler c'est dans des torts de
star académie aujourd'hui c'est le grand
soir
bienvenue soyez les bienvenus à star
académie que va-t-il se passer
la star academy ne récompense que les
meilleurs je vous rappelle qu'ils
étaient cent mille au départ je sais que
vous êtes impatients de découvrir les
visages des cinq ans d'un et finaliste
50 finalistes que vous avez sélectionné
chaque soir sur tf1 a lancé le moment
mesdames messieurs je vous demande de
leur faire un triomphe il mérite parce
qu'ils sont mort de trac
voici les 50 finaliste de la star
academy
[Applaudissements]
23 ans liège de noah 25 ans nantes
sidonie 27 ans paris jean pascal
saint-jean-de-luz
[Applaudissements]
il ya 21 ans carcassonne michael 26 ans
de paris
jennifer 18 ans françois wouts formation
et valérie benaïm je crois qu'ils
avaient pensé à vous pour animer la star
ac à un moment oui effectivement il
pensait et puis vous savez dans
télévision qu'on appelle des études et
ils font des études auprès d'un panel on
demande à ce que vous préférez un homme
ou une femme ait eu ce qui ressemble à
des études c'était plutôt l'on préfère
un homme pour animer parce qu'on croyait
pas à l'époque une famille tenir a
contraint comme ça et donc ils ont
enlevé des femmes de la liste et ils ont
gardé les hommes et les enfants valérie
vous auriez été magnifique et je suis
peut-être un et moi vous savez quoi eh
ben on va relancer non lancera tajine
academy à la rentrée on vend un tajine
et en même temps on chante we lose their
way moi j'ai c'est vrai que moi j'aimais
lié à l'époque la star ac mais il ya les
gentils réclamé que la saison 1 sur
youtube il ya une attente
bah oui on attend avec id confirmerait
confiner le oui merci
non juste avec sur la star à ce soit sur
la star ac comme sur le loft en fait
personne ne voulait me voulait a
présenté le programme moi je l'eus
programme là sur m6 parce que tout le
monde avait refusé on va pas se mentir
c'est donc la deûle tac tout le monde a
refusé flavie a refusé il nikos était un
peu comment à l'époque il était sûr
petite chaîne était inscrit 10 coeur
joie sur france info
wen jiabo effectivement il y aurait il à
il a pris le job et c'est vrai qu'au
début le pauvre il ya beaucoup souffert
parce qu'ils étaient malmenés dans par
les producteurs parce qu'effectivement
et était comme tout le monde j'ai
commencé il y avait eu 1 1
un fauteuil était balancé dans la baie
vitrée cap était dans le car et j'ai
tellement été déroutés et d'hervé sur ce
qui faisait alors que françoise est
criante de balle après il a cartonné
mine d'or mais c'est vrai que j'avais pu
la garder
au début il va 37 disais que c'était pas
assuré qu'au début ça a été dur là sans
gras strophe
les candidats ont su qu'ils allaient ou
intégrer ou non sa fameuse star academy
et c'était notamment le cas de jennifer
jennifer qu'ils étaient tranquillement
elle était à part puisque jennifer était
au soleil à ce moment-là comptable
[Musique]
à 18 ans jennifer a déjà un sacré
tempérament débordante d'énergie et
toujours enjoué cette belle niçoise a
décidé de prendre la vie du bon côté se
vit à 100 à l'heure je bouge tout le
temps j'adore la vie je laime la croque
à pleines dents vers dû avoir deux ans
deux ans et demi elle monte sort et fait
déguster avec des acrobaties et
aujourd'hui jennifer n'a rien perdu de
sa souplesse pour canaliser son trop
plein de vitalité
elle se défoulent dans le sport
au programme fitness box et footing ce
qui lui permet aussi de surveiller sa
ligne
une seule classe pour deux fils pour
deux filles qui veut devenir des stars
je vais vous donner
le nom de la gagnante la gagnante et
mesdames messieurs c'est la dernière
élèves c'est jennifer et oui et benjamin
la star academy je vous le dis c'est un
peu le ba-ba raconte avant le bas
raconte que le bahreïn
c'est vrai que le forcené le forcené
raconte le juste la star academy avait
pas et le marché aux départs incluant
mes papiers au départ il fait savoir qui
peut durant l'audience 1 à noter même
très très dur à tel point que il devait
arrêter le propre et mougeotte à
l'époque était le patron de tf1 avait
dit côté vous laisse encore une chance
si j'allais ça ne passe pas j'arrête
tout et c'est vrai que c'était pour tf1
c'était un enjeu économique considérable
il sauf que france 2 pour ce samedi là
où souvent avait mis un match de rugby
et graves a le rugby la ménagère s'est
déporté sur programme qui ensuite a
décollé au début c'était une catastrophe
totale nous raconte des choses
intéressantes je le fais pour raconter
quelque chose
allez-y c'est pour répondre à jean
michel eddé est ce qu'il ya des gens qui
réclament aujourd'hui toutes les
périodes d'avant à cause de ce combiné
farès merveilleuse mythique
donc oui on sort sur la nostalgie mais
jean-michel ça fait du bien ça fait
plaisir c'est un grand programme
familial donc c'est une très bonne idée
de faire ça même mais jean-michel je
vous le dis que j'avais l'air même vous
les jeux c'est une aussi belle que vous
avez un joueur vous avez des amitiés
mégantic le réseau lors du premier prime
on avait pu voir l'un des candidats
emblématiques de l'émission
là il y avait deux stars dans cette
premier premier épisode de la star ac
c'était jean pascal et jennifer jean
pascal qui nous rejoindra l'année
prochaine dont touche pas à mon poste je
voulais déjà dit puisque ça y est voilà
on sait rue voilà au téléphone je sais
qu'ils nous regardent actuellement
il avait d'ailleurs raconté sa petite
technique de drague regarder parce que
vous êtes redoutable en tout cas avec
les filles 1 on vous a vu vous êtes
galant toujours on regarde toujours
faire passer les fils de 20 ans ça leur
fait plaisir comme ça moi je peux le
regarder les fesses
[Applaudissements]
une copie du loft
les fans via son oui oui mon benji alors
un contenu juste pour vous dire à l
époque où ils ont lancé la star ac
la façade de la chanson c'était un
habillage pour faire la même chose que
sur m6 est en fait au début on a même
des interviews de dexia qui dit qu'elle
faisait pas tout mais il a tellement
réductrice la robe lui voilà qui
produisent et elle faisait pas de lui
dire qu'ils font mais la télé réalité
après ça a changé de mieux un vrai
talent show bien évidemment quand vous
voyez là vous voyez
l'autre facette de benjamin castaldi là
c'est à la fois benjamin c'est benjamin
que tout à l'heure
bien entendu je me retourne du forcené